foreign
comes as a surprise to people when I
tell them that I do the majority of the
cooking in my house now do I cook
because I want to challenge gender
stereotypes or do I cook because I'm a
sexist and I believe that men make
better chefs or do I cook simply because
I enjoy it and I'm good at it theories
abound but nobody can say for sure
whatever the reason for my cooking it is
partly because I cook so much that that
I reacted with special horror and took
it personally when I read the news this
week the bite Administration wants to
confiscate my gas stove and yours
everyone's the New York Post reports
quote the by Administration is
considering a nationwide ban on gas
stoves citing the harmful pollutants
released by the appliances according to
a report the consumer product safety
commission is mulling the action after
recent studies showed emissions from the
devices can cause health and respiratory
problems this is a hidden Hazard cpsc
commissioner Richard trumka Jr told the
outlet any option is on the table
products that can't be made safe
can be banned reports by the groups by
groups including the American Chemical
Society and New York University law
schools Institute for policy Integrity
found that gas stoves which are used in
40 of U.S homes while the remainder use
various forms of electric cookers emit
pollutants like nitrogen dioxide carbon
monoxide and fine moderate levels deemed
unsafe by the Environmental Protection
Agency and the World Health Organization
the studies also link gastos to
respiratory illness cardiovascular
problems cancer and other health
conditions more than 12 percent of
childhood asthma cases can be attributed
to gas stoves according to a report
published last month by the
international Journal of Environmental
Research and Public Health
not only that by the way but AOC who
predictably jumped on the anti-gast
stove bandwagon tweeted that gas stoves
along with giving you cancer and Asthma
and destroying the planet can also cause
brain damage
and gas stoves aren't the only
appliances on The Chopping Block States
like California New York have already
moved to ban gas heaters like anything
run on gas must be prohibited apparently
starting with the stoves is what we're
being told
yes people have been cooking with gas
since the 1820s
you may have grown up in houses that
only ever had gas stoves millions and
millions of people have been using gas
stoves for decade upon decade without
any issue but now suddenly it's a crisis
and people who never mentioned the
crisis before
people who never said anything about the
fact that gas stoves are giving us
tumors and destroying our brains are all
quite certain now that it is happening
and they insist that drastic action be
taken in response
none of us from gas stove households
ever noticed people being struck down
with cancer or losing their minds
because of the stove
everything seemed to be working just
fine
there didn't appear to be any issue at
all
but there is an issue it turns out a
very big issue a deadly issue people are
dying they are dying
and so we must consent to whatever
exorbitant measures the powers that be
prescribe
or not
here's why
just to summarize here's why I will not
consent to this war on gas stoves and
they will have to pry my gas stove from
my cold dead hands or warm hands as the
case may be first there is no compelling
evidence for any of the claims they are
now making what they have are a handful
of studies funded you know usually by
activist groups speculating that gas
stoves may have some link maybe to some
health problems possibly perhaps in
theory
of course you could conduct a study
finding a theoretical link between
literally any object or food or activity
and any health problem
this is easy to do if you set out with
the intention of finding the link
second a big part of the concern is
about the supposed environmental danger
CBS News reported recently gas stoves
are contributing more to global warming
than previously thought because they
constantly leak small amounts of methane
even while they're off a new study has
found the same study also found that
home stoves can emit high levels of
nitrogen oxides raising concerns about
health and indoor air quality even when
they are not running U.S gas stoves are
putting 2.6 million tons of methane in
carbon dioxide equivalent units into the
air each year A Team of California
researchers found in a study published
Thursday in the journal Environmental
Science and Technology that's equivalent
to the annual amount of greenhouse gases
from 500 000 cars or what the U.S puts
into the air every three and a half
hours
yes you're not only killing your
children with the gas stove you're also
killing the polar bears and the entire
planet with it
but what is the plan here okay if we're
supposed to believe that fossil fuels
are destroying the planet
what happens when we get rid of the gas
stoves
and we convert 40 million households
over to Electric all at once
and have increased our electricity usage
by that much
electricity is largely generated by
fossil fuels also so even by the
environmentalist's own logic aren't you
simply Shifting the problem not solving
it
third Point gas stoves work they just
simply work they work far better than
electric stuff they cook more evenly and
efficiently they can be controlled more
precisely an electric stove is fine for
like heating up a can of soup or maybe
even fry maybe even frying an egg
I wouldn't try to scramble an egg on an
electric stove but you can at least fry
one maybe
but that's the extent of its abilities
most real cooking requires careful
temperature control something that isn't
possible on an electric stove not only
that but electric stoves are harder to
clean they're more expensive to operate
over the course of a year
so this is yet another example of
leftist bureaucrats wanting to take
something away that is more affordable
and more functional
and which has been working fine for
millions of people for many years
and they want to do that in favor of
something crappier and more expensive
and they do all of this based on flimsy
cherry-picked data compiled by activists
who almost always stand to profit
somehow from the change they're
advocating this is what left-wing
bureaucrats do they themselves are
inefficient and useless and so they
instinctively hate anything that is
efficient and useful
they basically want every aspect of Our
Lives to be as haphazard and
dysfunctional as the agencies they run
that's that's essentially the the goal
here
fourth
finally
as always there is the hypocrisy Factor
AOC has uh has you know she's saying now
that that gas stoves cause brain damage
and yet she has taken Instagram videos
in her kitchen where you can clearly see
the gas stove in the background
which come to think of it may actually
lend some Credence to the theory that
gas stoves cause brain damage I mean to
explain a lot in her case anyway Jill
Biden was also photographed in her own
Kitchen in 2020 with a gas stove
and of course these people all have
gases gas stoves are better and the
elites obviously prefer the better thing
over the inferior thing
they just don't want you to have it
you can make do with your electric stove
you pee on
besides you're supposed to be eating
bugs anyway you don't need a stove for
that
that's the attitude
which is why we must respond no I will
not eat the bugs
I will not live in the pod
I will not overcook my chicken stir-fry
on an incompetent electric stove I won't
do it
instead I will say to those who wage war
on the gas stove you are all canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]